one
[ __ ] tournaments most immediate joy
comes from something simple to Pokemon
physically interacting this may seem
trivial to most but for longtime fans is
the opportunity to finally scratch an
itch that's been out of reach for 20
years in the RPG series battles have
been very static with back-and-forth
wobbles representing two pokemon
attacking each other that changes with
[ __ ] tournament and it's a delight to
see Nintendo's iconic Pokemon finally
free to leap around and trade blows up
close but what makes it bear is that
there's a satisfying set of fighting
game mechanics underpinning it all these
are deep and technical but also retain
the accessibility and tactical spirit of
the RPG series
that'll display into two phases which
the game constantly shifts between the
fuel phase is focused on using ranged
attacks from a distance then at the
right moment using a homing attack to
deliver a powerful follow-up the beauty
of the field phase is that it creates
strategy in simplicity both players have
the same objectives and the tools at the
disposal to complete those the focus is
on firing and dodging projectiles
maneuvering into an advantageous
position and in capitalizing it's
thrilling in the same way that thumb
wrestling is two players pecking at each
other waiting for that perfect moment to
go for a pimp in the dual phase the game
becomes like Tekken and Street Fighter
buying game aficionados will understand
the mechanics at play here instinctively
the newcomers can quickly get
comfortable with the logic light attacks
are quicker than heavy ones but do far
less damage those blocking high are
vulnerable to sweeps and throws are
reliable way to punish turtling
and then there's counter-attacks which
let you hit back through an enemy's
assault [ __ ] is a game laced with
small ideas and design feats but one of
the most important is that it offers
depth with our overwhelming new players
the majority of special moves for
example can be executed with a single
button pressed with specific timing and
more button presses combos can become
complex but they always seem master able
by beautifully striking they're balanced
pokken is not just a successful
cross-pollination of two game series
it's an outright excellent entry point
into fighting games on top of the core
mechanics are technicalities that give
the game replayability
for example picking the right pokémon to
battle requires some thought you want
Charizard who is slow and powerful or
we-well which is weak or very fast then
there's unique attributes and abilities
for each Pokemon that can cater to
different styles of play braixen can
increase her damage for a short period
but sceptile can leech health from an
enemy you can choose great applying
pressure but Machamp can take a beam
poor characters are another of pockets
gameplay wrinkles and a clever way to
draw from the series's turn-based
tactical routes it allows players to
select a Pokemon to lend a hand in
battle advantage is the support Pokemon
provide range from directly attacking
the other player to setting up traps and
giving stat benefits synergy is another
new ability by filling a gauge players
can trigger a mega evolution for the
Pokemon that have one or a powerup state
for those that don't
in this mode moves are enhanced and the
Pokemon also has access to a synergy
burst these are powerful cinematic
special attacks that without
understatement are stunning to behold
pokken tournament presentation is
lovingly crafted for the slick broadcast
style for its battles and each of its 19
stages filled with eye candy and
fanservice the Pokemon themselves are
just as full of life if you want to
explain to someone why you find Pokemon
so charming this is the game you should
reach for out of the box
Hakan is a fully featured fighting game
packed with gameplay modes customization
features and a comprehensive training
suite the meat of the single player is
the firmly in which players fight
through five skill tiers to be crowned
ultimate champion we throughout this is
the story of a corrupted Mewtwo which is
a nice touch that alleviates the
monotony of grinding through qualifying
matches it's a testament to the quality
of pokken tournament that I just wish
there were more characters there's more
than 600 Pokemon now and [ __ ]
tournament features just 16 of those
perhaps this is an unfair criticism
since this number is similar to what
most fighting game rosters launch at but
I simply need more I need hawlucha
otherwise pokken tournament is
magnificent to look at delicately
designed and rewarding for players
across all skill levels
it's the pokemon fighting game we
deserve after a 20-year way
good
you
you